protect your bubble calm proud sponsors
of swipe on Sky News you're watching
spike on the show this week digital then
we look at the apps and gadgets that
could help you to keep calm watch what
happens when I try to find my inner
balance and should they renamed it
mindcraft
the titles that could help you unwind in
our games early
hello and welcome to swipe this week we
come to a Buddhist Center because we're
learning how to let go of stress and
worry and really focus on being in the
moment but there's a tech twist of
course there is this is a tech show I've
been looking at weather distressing
influences like the ones found in places
like these can translate through
technology everyone take a deep breath
welcome to this two-minute pause in your
day judging by the number of meditation
apps like these on offer perhaps
learning how to switch off is something
more and more of us are trying to master
life isn't always easy sometimes there
are a lot more clouds in the sky there
are apps to teach you how to be mindful
focusing your thoughts on the present
the technique is becoming so popular one
UK charity is called for mindfulness
classes to be made available nationally
on the NHS become aware the rising and
sinking of the natural breath in your
belly music producer Peter Rolls created
his own meditation apps to deal with the
stress in his life after developing
chillax a collection of relaxing sounds
he teamed up with a Buddhist monk to
develop his next called Zen ways so it's
been about how to find ways that people
here in the West can access what Zen is
really about no I'm quite skeptical
about all these things you know
I've got a very sciency background as
well as the creative side and I take all
these sort of new-age theories with a
kind of pinch of salt most at a time but
I mean I've had some really really
powerful experiences doing this
meditation but if zoning out to relaxing
sounds just isn't you tech developers
aren't short of alternatives the makers
behind the muse headband call it the
mental equivalent of a treadmill
training you to become aware of your
distraction so you can learn to focus
better and improve how you handle stress
while spires clip-on technology measures
breathing patterns and tells you when
you're tense before guiding you back to
calm this may all sound rather
surprising to anyone who previously
thought tech was actually a cause of
stress you're not gonna put Pandora's
box back right we're not gonna we're not
gonna suddenly throw away all of our
phone
our email our connection that's that's a
fact of modern life so how do we use
this technology to also create common
and focus in our day o night here's one
to sleep on a pillow that vibrates and
plays music only you can hear
although try not to get too attached to
your new tools if we're just relying on
an app it might take us away from the
social aspect which is so important so
sometimes a really good way of managing
our stress might be to engage with with
other people those with an eye on the
futures they Tech is helping us to be
more we've got a trend that we call the
optimized self which is people now
taking technology and data and using it
for themselves and making themselves a
better person stronger person fitter
person better memory better eyesight
well if self optimization includes
sitting quietly and thinking nice
thoughts I'm all for it well learning
how to relax and switch off can
sometimes take a bit of practice and
with me now is Gavin Andrews from heart
math UK I'm going to come and sit down
next to you because you've got some kit
here which can help us to practice
relaxing how do you how does it all work
this is according inner balance trainer
and it gives you biofeedback on your
heart rhythms what it's things you to do
is to practice learning a technique
called coherence so coherence is a state
of balance and optimal state so we want
to be care and we want to be coherent
especially when we're stressed press
make smart people do stupid things so we
put this on your ear
this is an infrared sensor and it's
picking up your heart rhythm see if you
could pop a crocodile click just on your
black piece so each one of these bumps
is you're in a very crazy pole it is
it's entirely normal don't worry you
think it's called an ambulance but what
we're seeing here what we're measuring
actually is the gaps between each of
these pulses and then that enables us to
create a waveform so what you're seeing
here is actually your heart rhythm in
real-time how do I train myself to chill
out this is a mandala and it's a breath
pacer
so I'd like you to focus your attention
on the one-dollar and now I want you to
focus your attention on the area of your
heart mm-hmm
now you've got your attention there I
want you to imagine the breath flowing
into and out of the heart chest area and
now we want to go to a higher level
so what we're going to do is I would
like you to recall something or someone
for which you have genuine care or
appreciation okay I'm going to think
about my baby nephew the baby nephew is
perfect okay imagine those things of
care and appreciation for your nephew
flowing into and out of the hot area
it's green it's gone green it's gone
green already what does that mean it
means that you're in coherence as I said
thinking of my nephew has really relaxed
me absolutely thinking about people we
care for and love puts us in a state of
balance so when would be best for
someone to use this will it be the night
before something nerve-wracking or
immediately before well certainly I mean
just in general we recommend five
minutes three times a day but if you
know you've got something stressful
coming up then yeah spend a bit of extra
time on it the night before and then
maybe even if you're traveling in on the
train or a bus the next day you could
use it again then thanks for thanks for
showing me how to relax and thank you
for coming to the Buddhist temple today
my pleasure
enjoy being coherent Thanks you're
watching Slyke coming up our blocks and
pixels are key to unwinding games for
calming down in our review but first
here's a roundup of some of this week's
other tech news
Spotify beefed up its offerings this
week by launching a new version with
video podcasts radio and news other
features include customized playlists
for runners based on their speed the
music streaming company is facing stiff
competition
jay-z launched tidal in March while
Apple is expected to set up a dedicated
music streaming service soon to
conveniently keeping with our well being
theme this week an energy boosting
wearable began crowdfunding on IndieGoGo
the people behind io say it's special
blue light helps you wake up easily feel
energized and minimized jet lag a build
your own video game system also launched
on a crowdfunding site this week block
souls on Kickstarter lets you use
physical bricks to design your own game
layout you then take a picture and play
it on your phone or tablet it's being
touted as a potential tool to get kids
interested in game building and coding
now it just wouldn't be right ruin our
newfound calm by introducing a load of
violent fantasy or shoot-'em-up video
for our review this week so instead we
asked Chris to pick a few of his
favorite titles to unwind to journey is
it's a very relaxing game I say it's got
some sort of puzzle elements to it for
the main gist of it being a game
developed by that games company it's on
the ps4 Ian's coming out on the ps4 is
you just sort of float around as a
little sort of celestial sort of body
looking thing and the main relaxation
comes from it's the soundtrack because
as you go along it's just beautiful and
all you're doing is going forward
constantly that's the whole point in the
game go forward and there's a little
interactions with people and I like most
games where it's sort of someone
shouting in your headphones angrily it's
just a little low beeping noise that you
can interact with someone with just so
long as you go along and it's beautiful
you get into these states of just
travelling forward where you reach a
sort of Zen state where you're just all
you're thinking is I need to go forward
and it's beautiful game animal crossing
new leaf it's a game on the Nintendo 3ds
came out about a year or so ago
ridiculously relaxing game you just sit
down with your 3ds and the main
interaction for the game are just
talking to the little towns folk they're
just made up that Lana Moore's like the
Penguins and bears running around you
get a house you go plant flowers you can
dig up fossils if you want and sell them
to make a little bit some money so you
can improve your house just hang out and
have a good time of animals in an
imaginary world minecraft which is
available in everything now from like
mobile devices to the most high-end
PlayStation 4 and Xbox ones it's doesn't
seem like it's a relaxing games on the
outset you know you're being attacked by
monsters and all things like that at
night and you've got to hide you can
skip all of that just go straight into
the building mode and then you can fly
around you don't even have to think
about collecting anything you're just
building and you get a group of friends
together it's one of the life's like
rewarding and relaxing things you can do
with friends because again no threat
nothing like that no time limits just
sit there and build and people have
built mad things like I've built the
entire Starship Enterprise and like
working computers and so further out
which I think in modern society where
not a lot of us get to actually build
it's quite relaxing to actually let out
that side of you that you sit and create
things
well that's it for this week but don't
forget you can stay up to date with all
the latest tech news on sky knees for
iPad our smartphone apps sky nice calm
and our YouTube channel I'll see you
again next week bye bye protect your
bubble calm proud sponsors of swipe on
Sky News